Before we say goodbye,
we love to play a quick round of?
Drewth or Dare.
(audience cheers)
(Drew cheers)
All right, so we have Devon in our audience.
Hi Devon.
Hi.
All right, so what's it gonna be Drewth or dare?
I have a dare.
Ooh.
So, my family loves pickles.
My grandmother actually used to make
the best homemade pickles.
Really?
And since Drew got to try pickles on the show.
I have a dare for you, Ross.
Oh!
It was fun until you said that, okay.
I dare you to try a pickle split sundae.
A pickle split sundae?
A pickle split sundae.
Okay, now what is a pickle split sundae?
I guess it's like a banana split
but with pickles instead of bananas.
Thank you, angel.
Ooh!
Okay, this actually is like a banana split sundae
with pickles, okay.
Oh my God, it smells so good.
Okay.
Do you know the chocolate covered pickle
was actually surprisingly not bad.
At first I was like, "Oh."
And then I was like, "Mm."
Okay, I'm really gonna relish every bite of this ah ha.
Oh God, okay.
Mm-mm, mm-mm, mm-mm.
(Drew laughs)
Nope, nope. that's not, mm-mm.
You wanna try it?
I love, God, darn it.
Mm.
Yeah
I'm telling, I love pickles.
I'll eat just the pickle.
If it was with the chocolate ice cream
that's a no go for me, okay.
It's queried.
Devon, is this something that you do?
No, definitely not.
How did this come about?
I'm sorry, you don't do this?
Absolutely not.
Oh, you will now.
(Devon laughs)
I got one for your right here, Devon,
with your name on it.
Thank you, Devon so much.
Thanks for getting him too.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody so much
for choosing to spend your time with us.
We make this show for you.
So, take it with you.
Take it with you!
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪